méxico comenzó a retirar migrantes
haitianos que permanecían desde hace
días varados en el puente internacional
que conecta la ciudad de acuña coahuila
con del río texas agentes del instituto
mexicano de emigración la mañana de este
martes transportaron en autobuses
foráneos a 120 migrantes haitianos al
aeropuerto de piedras negras coahuila
para subir los abuelos que los llevaron
a villahermosa tabasco a tapachula
chiapas para que desde ahí puedan
continuar con sus trámites de pedir
asilo a washington aunque ya los han
rechazado solicitar refugio a mexico o
bien participar en un programa de
retorno asistido a su país el riesgo que
corren los migrantes haitianos y
centroamericanos al atravesar mexico es
caer en las manos del crimen organizado
que suele reclutar los para cometer
prácticas delictivas
el canciller mexicano marcelo ebrard
dijo que los migrantes haitianos están
siendo víctimas de un engaño monumental
por parte de líderes que les hacen la
falsa promesa de que eeuu les dará la
residencia dijo que de este tema habló
con el secretario de estado de eeuu
anthony blinken a quien le planteó la
necesidad
una solución regional a esta
problemática derivada de la crisis en
haití